le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais à la réunion
la moitié des moins de 20 ans vit en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté et près de
60% des actifs de moins de 25 ans sont à
la recherche d'un emploi le conseil
général a bâti un plan ambitieux avec
l'opération parrainage 4000 jeunes les
premiers et marraines et parrains ont
été trouvés et répondu présent place
maintenant aux échanges et aux
engagements mutuels
à quoi sert ce bénévolat pourquoi les
jeunes ont-ils besoin dead est il
possible avec ces aides de réussir son
plan de vie on en parle tout de suite
dans lien social
notre île à une population jeune en
forte croissance démographique
c'est une chance un atout pour l'avenir
mais c'est aussi de grandes difficultés
pour le présent même si ce n'est pas de
la compétence légale du conseil général
la collectivité a initié il y a deux ans
l'académie des dalons s'adressant à ce
public de jeunes
après plusieurs mois ces jeunes sont
reçus stabiliser remise en confiance en
internat puis en contrats de service
civique dans la continuité de l'académie
des dalons a été initié l'opération
parrainage avec dans un premier temps
170 hommes pour à terme concerner 4000
jeunes il s'agit d'un engagement
tripartite entre le conseil général
un jeune et un par un pour permettre à
ce jeune de bâtir en projet de vie et
d'insertion durable dans la société
le parrain officiel de cette opération
yannick noah nous dit combien il est
nécessaire d'aller jusqu'au bout ce
projet je pense un très bon projet et je
suis très content et fier d'être d'être
le parrain je pense qu'il faut qu'il y
ait un suivi
je crois vraiment à 7 ce travail de
proximité parce qu'il s'agit pas tout
d'un coup devenir une fois discuté puis
partir il faut qu'ils s'installent une
vraie relation
et puis après les énergies mais ce se
partager s'additionnent ce qui compte
c'est les coûts' écouté que je les
écoute qui m'écoutent quand on décide
une direction et qu'on ait rien fondre à
saint joseph
davina 24 ans est maman d'un petit
garçon de 2 ans recherche un emploi
je suis actuellement la recherche
d'emploi pour me permettre
de macérer dans le milieu professionnel
et ainsi dans la société
je suis dans l'association un serrano
depuis le début de l'année cette
association m'a permis de prendre
confiance en moi de m'affirmer en tant
que personne ça m'a beaucoup aidé aussi
au niveau de recherche d'emploi au
niveau des cv des lacs motivation avec
johan ans se voit une fois par semaine
pour faire le bilan de mes démarches
je paie elle appelé aussi le soir
d'envoyer des textos pour pour avoir des
conseils
la marraine johanna et coach à
l'association 1 sert à nous de saint
joseph
elle nous parle de son métier qu'elle
pratique avec passion et coeur que je
fais aujourd'hui auprès de deux
personnes sur saint-joseph notamment est
sûr c'est un fait que c'est en totale
adéquation totale corrélation avec mon
métier et les métiers des
accompagnatrices sociale et
professionnelle
dans un premier temps c'est vraiment
écouter la personne
donc c'est une relation des d'aussi
écouter et entendre entendre mais pas
conseillé quelques la personne prenne
conscience aussi 20 de ce qu'elle est de
la connaître mais dans son passé dans le
présent et
voir travailler pour son futur
dans un deuxième temps c'est de définir
son projet son projet professionnel
son projet de vie dans toutes les
dimensions que ce soit au niveau
familial émotionnel
culturel et je pense que ce dispositif
les dispositifs du plan cadre niggel
parrainer il entre en totale
totale adéquation je pense que c'est une
main tendue vers le jeune même si on a
le soutien de la cellule familiale de
ses enfants de ses parents de son
conjoint
le fait d'avoir une personne extérieure
c'est une main c'est une autre mais
c'est un autre type de main content
content à la personne et des fois ça ça
peut dégager autre chose il n'est pas
question d'assister ces jeunes mais bien
de leur apporter une réponse rapide
autant que possible positive sans les
envoyés de porte à porte
un accompagnement une aide pour leur
ouvrir des portes
ce sera bien à eux de se mobiliser pour
atteindre leurs objectifs
ce projet parrainage 4000 jeunes se veut
être un dispositif innovant et salvateur
une action publique déterminé visant à
permettre à chaque jeune en situation
d'exclusion de retrouver l'estimé de soi
et d'acquérir un savoir être et un
savoir faire indispensables au
développement de ses potentialités et à
l'accès à l'emploi
tous les ingrédients sont là implication
motivation mobilisation c'est désormais
aux jeunes réunionnais de construire
leur avenir
une réunion solidaire dynamique et
ambitieuse pour donner à chacun les
chances auquel il a droit
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais